[Music]
Selena Gomez and her sister Gracie
dazzling designer at the Golden Globes I
love it
that cell rocking a velvet gown by
Valentino featuring a high slit and
eggplant colored sleeves it was a big
night for the actress who was a first
time Golden Globe nominee so of course
she had to bring someone special that
being her little sis Gracie she's my
biggest supporter yep a Selena posed on
the carpet she's sweetly called up the
nine-year-old to join her Gracie Dons a
yellow dress and tulle skirt but it was
her designer bag that really stole the
show oh my goodness it's a product Cleo
satin purse with crystals and the price
tag well it runs close to four thousand
dollars I don't think my sister
overthinks anything and that's what I
love about her she enjoys it she's
excited about life this isn't the first
red carpet the sister Duo have hit
together in 2019 selling Gracie Rock
matching outfits at the Frozen 2
premiere a cute moment we can't let go
Let It Go
Selena's shared many adorable moments
with her sister over the years I mean
the two are basically Tick-Tock
Sensations together I just deleted the
whole time
yeah remember the time Selena tried to
prove she was social media Savvy and
Gracie totally teased her about it you
embarrassed me
deleted the whole time
this is where it's at Snapchat is where
wait what
then there's their lip sync of this
classic Full House moment
I'm
not falling for that she's awesome she's
just there to have a good time and when
Selena and Gracie aren't making tick
tocks together they're hanging out with
their close friends including Nicola
Peltz Beckham it's really cool back in
November the gals had a girls night
celebrating the release of cells
documentary my mind and me the trio
cozied up in pink matching PJs alongside
other close friends so as soon as we
find out who you are trust you will be
dealt with period enjoying my life and
I'm getting to do things that I'm
passionate about with the people that I
love and they recently celebrated
Nicholas Birthday Selena shared this
sweet pic of them planting kisses on her
cheeks writing in the caption it's not
your B-day yet but let's celebrate now
with Nicholas sweetly responding OMG my
sisters with heart emojis
foreign